what Wilkinson err are interested in the
visitors to this gallery should get is
is the sheer wonder of actually all not
just the objects and the technology but
in a way a kind of emotional connection
the human experience of Medicine and you
get it all here the first thing the
visitors will come across three meter
high bronze statue by Mark Quinn
fantastic focal point creates the first
Vista can be seen kind of right from the
other side of the eastern hall that this
really puts the visitor and human body
right in front of the narrative so we
have strip back to the basic
architecture so things that in a sense
was superfluous and somehow didn't look
as if they belong we've taken a lot of
things out but one of the other things
we've done is let the day light in so
you get these changes in pace from light
to dark you bring the outside world into
into the space don't think it should
always be about sort of removing people
from reality and always be black box one
of the key things he was crate these
vistas they would draw visitors through
the spaces and we spent a lot of time
placing objects open display all kind of
lighting them dramatically or having
mass displays to draw people across I
think that's particularly important when
you get to the void over the making wall
in the world and you actually can see
right across the gallery and I can are
drawn in by large-scale AV or amazing
objects we're trying to turn in a sense
what's three galleries into into one
gallery so we're going through a
sequence of spaces and in the middle of
them was a big array of lifts and it was
fundamental as to how we could make that
the two main parts of the gallery feel
connected and I think we've really
succeeded with that and a number of ways
that we've done it one is having a
unifying floor finish running through
this rather beautiful wooden floor and
the other is to actually cloak the lifts
in a whole range of objects they act as
sort of partly to terminate vistas but
also to take you on to the next
so it feels you feel as a continuity
here which I think that the outset
looked quite difficult but we were
always thinking about it
with this being an object rich gallery
one of the challenges was how to display
the cases with the appropriate
environmental conditions that they all
require but also without creating a
barrier between the visitor and the
objects the design of the display cases
have their technical challenges but
we've used non reflective glass
practically frameless and so you get
close and personal with the objects
another key element was communicating
the themes to the visitor we've got a
lot of objects and a lot of different
themes so we work very close with
interpretation team and the graphic
design team and came up with the kind of
graphical hierarchy of totems which work
as signals as you go through the
galleries probably a highlighting
particular section focus object or even
key objects within the narratives at the
far western end of the gallery we have
another threshold space the look in the
feel of this space was in contrast of
the others basis it's meant to feel kind
of quite intimate and a kind of certain
a space where you can sit and kind of
think about all the stories you've come
across and your journey through the
other galleries we design this right and
we get this right in every way that we
can that the gallery will last 2025
years and that you'll come in in 20
years time and it'll still look quite
fresh and if we can do that then I think
we've really achieved something
you